hi everyone Sal here from Khan Academy
and I just wanted to make an
announcement of something that I think
many of you will find useful I have a
little bit of a side project going on
called schoolhouse dot world it isn't an
official Khan Academy project but it's a
way to get free tutoring yes I'm talking
about free live tutoring what happens on
schoolhouse dot world is you as a
student can go and say what areas and
we're starting with high school math
what areas of high school math you need
help in and you can see existing
tutoring sessions that are scheduled in
the coming days and coming weeks and on
the other side we have volunteer tutors
who look at what students what you might
need help in and will schedule these
group tutoring sessions so whether
you're interested in being a student and
getting some free live help or whether
you're interested in being a tutor or
both
check out schoolhouse dot world there's
a little bit of a registration process
this is really a startup project right
now where we're trying to make sure we
balance the tutors and the students but
I'll tell you right now we have an
incredible number of amazing tutors and
actually we're looking for more students
to tutor so check it out fill out the
form and you will be able to get some
help and you know the view is you can
learn your own time and pace on Khan
Academy obviously we have the exercises
the feedback there you have the videos
we just launched our get ready for grade
level courses you can use that as well
and then when you need in-person help
you can go to schoolhouse dot world